body armor okay ar-15s I make seven
hostile
I make five
for
run lows on the third floor Wanda just
like we practiced what about the guests
get it out
we need me put a check
Tony safe his hands are still our own
it doesn't have to end in a fight
sometimes I want to punch you in your
perfect teeth
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie new Captain
America footage dropped at the MTV Movie
Awards so let's break it down it's
really just an example of the Avengers
working together like the New Avengers
working together to take down crossbones
you here at cap say rumlow that's Brock
rumlow who is crossbones which we see in
this scene punching Captain America with
his gear on his crossbones gear one of
my favorite things since winter soldier
about you know like the media they do
around these Marvel movies is Frank
Grillo the actor who plays crossbones
just teasing Chris Evans like I'm coming
back for you for round two pretty boy I
can't remember if that's his actual
nickname for Chris Evans but this looks
like it's happening relatively early in
the film like from the very first act of
the film think back to Avengers age of
Ultron in how they were all working
together to take down Baron von
strucker's lab Thor banged his hammer on
cap she'll just showing how they learned
to use their powers and really new
interesting ways now they're doing that
with Scarlet Witch and cap she picks him
up with her telekinesis and throws him
into the building also can't wait to see
Falcon use red wing red wing in the
comics is an actual Falcon that helps
him out and in the movies they're just
making it an advanced military drone so
expect some really cool red wing stuff
right now it just looks like cap is
trying to track down crossbows to kick
the [ __ ] out of them before maybe this
giant explosion happens this looks like
set up for their version of the Stanford
incident from civil war in the comics
but winter soldier is probably gonna be
a big part of that so there's a lot
we're not singing this clip but as you
guys may have heard they screened the
movie at cinemacon the whole movie
there's an embargo up for review so
nobody is able to post our actual review
but everyone's really positive on it I
mean it's not like people were jacking
off in a theater it's gonna be awesome
within reason but people are still
saying like it's going to have to crush
it to beat Deadpool at the box office so
right now Deadpool is the movie to beat
financially which I totally think
Captain America can do but I usually I
don't pay attention to box offices or
anything like that if you like the movie
if you hate the movie that's really all
that matters and speaking of stuff that
people really liked they said there's
about 10 minutes of Peter Parker in the
new film 20 minutes full 20 minutes of
spider-man and everyone that I've seen
talking about the movie that's actually
seen it says that this is the best
version of spider-man that they've ever
seen so we are most definitely entering
a shut up and take my money situation
but I'm not actually going to post a
review till it hits theaters everywhere
so don't worry about that I haven't seen
the movie early once it does drop I'll
totally do my nonce
we review first then I'll do spoilers
Easter eggs all that stuff in related
news there's also supposed to be some
new Suicide Squad footage so if that
drops then I'll totally do a video for
it be sure to subscribe to get that if
there's any other bonus Marvel videos
you guys want me to do just let me know
in the comments not really a big fan of
award shows but I'm always a big fan
when they drop new footage well you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here to learn all about power girl
maybe coming on the flash season 3 and
you can click here for my Star Wars
rogue one trailer video thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you